you accept
your skills regardless of the outcome
yes
i don't look good
oh what did you do
oh
my entire life are you sure
with that accent
your entire life what did you see
where do you think all those soldiers
were marching to lady
you ain't gonna kill this old lady come
on now come on now
you ain't gonna do that
[Applause]
she's gonna do something bad she's gonna
call the cops and some kids in her front
yard like i know they're up to no good
bring my god
she's like dried out she got like dried
out yo arthur harrow is a he's a freak
she she should have stopped driving me
maybe way earlier
or something like that
who knows how many people she related
some real bad [ __ ]
or will or will
we definitely dodged a bullet with that
with that one
oh man oh man welcome back to new
rockstars moon night episode one proves
that even golden girls can have their
worst days ahead of them but unlike cult
leaders mt and i have been suckered into
following arthur harrow's got the true
egyptian demon powers to back up the
kool-aid god i'm naming
[Applause]
this is inside marvel it's new rockstars
after show for marvel's moon night on
disney plus i'm eric boss i'm here with
mt
dude uh i think that old lady might need
some uh medical assistance she's not
looking too good what do you think uh
yeah she's looking a lot more uh drier
than she first appeared um yeah uh
losing a bit of color looking like uh
you know one division episode one a
little bit oh for sure it's black and
white
also the one finale with uh those
witches when they when they got uh
sucked out um or how about uh the
visions finale and infinity war kind of
kind of gray
i think that's the best one there yeah
100 she's 100 dead there general
thoughts for this first episode mt what
was what was your feelings coming out of
this dude like it was obviously like uh
it's a little bit of a slow start
because like we don't see moon knight
straight out the gate but the ending of
this episode gave me so many goosebumps
that i had to rewatch it over and over
again because like this is the best one
of the best intros to a marvel hero that
we've ever gotten in my opinion like
my god like so badass but what do you
think some of the best character
development i think we've ever seen in
the institute some of the best acting
we've ever seen in the mcu from from
oscar isaac good lord amazing
here and and i love the fact that we
start with ethan hawk starting with this
creepy cult villain from the get-go one
of my favorite introductions to a
different side of the world uh there's
so much mystery
the more you dig back into this episode
you realize wait there's there's so much
to question right
so many loose ends so many little sub
mysteries that pop up we're going to
talk about all of this yes in this
episode uh in our first of this moon
night after show series so let's dig
into it this first episode introduces us
to ethan hawk as the cult leader arthur
harrow jamming out to some bob dylan
christ rock while lining his sandals
with broken glass this guy's the real
deal oh never brings it
so gruesome yeah like everything
never even winces uh now it's
fascinating that we start with this guy
especially the fact that he's arthur
harrow a really a nobody villain in moon
knight comics it's made us all think
that he might be revealed to be someone
else he might have some kind of
additional identity uh revealed later on
or he just might not be exactly the name
arthur hero we'll find out but uh oscar
isaac we begin with him playing the
awkward bumbling stephen grant a british
loser who thinks he has a sleepwalking
problem uh and uh he's really an ancient
history nerd he calls his mom on the
phone we don't hear the mom talking so
who knows if there is anyone on the
other end there he's got a fish gus
um with just one fin like nemo i love
how they call that out later the episode
um he's not enough to sleep obviously he
has some kind of sleep condition but he
works in a london museum gift shop with
uh the bully donna who's just all over
the worst literally the worst like come
on donna like give him a break come on
come on donna
uh
the security guard who won't remember
his name
but he's uh he's making some connections
with some other employees he's got a
date set up he's a vegan but i mean he's
still oscar at the end of the day
at the end of the day the guy doesn't
even need to open his mouth exactly just
get get a shot of uh duke leto atreides
from that side angle lean it back in
this corpse
that's all i need
[Laughter]
don't even got to be alive
reveal themselves as necrophilia
well bound to happen
bound to happen he talks to uh a
gold painted street performer it's
apparently his best friend
uh he straps his leg at night to try to
stay awake but then he wakes up face
down in the alps running from gunman
trying to recover a golden scarab
artifact with egyptian hieroglyphics
that he stole from them from one of
their castles that are all over the alps
uh and then stephen uh runs down to the
village where he sees arthur harrow uh
with a gathering of his cult uh
performing this creepy judgment ritual
using the tattoo of emmitt scales to
judge their past present future morality
this old woman fails the test gets her
life force sucked out whoops this leads
to a of an epic chase steven going in
and out of consciousness where he wakes
up like brutally savaging his pursuers
yeah kill the couple taking them out
with logs all from behind the wheel of a
cupcake delivery truck exciting exciting
sequence here taking a cue from a wanda
vision just uh just completely just
demolishing things in a truck like she
like uh what's your favorite darts
yeah for sure
he wakes up on this mountain road
thinking it was all a dream but then he
just notices these little glitches in
the matrix like the vicious fin has
grown back several days have passed
causing him to miss the date um he
orders his steak medium well which or no
just well done right which is just
painful to see
order a fillet
well done i just i can't handle that
listen man i always order my meat well
done i'm one of those people i always
get it i have to make sure all the
bacteria is dead eric i have to make
sure the breast
does stay just promise me if you order a
well done steak just get make it like a
new york strip don't get a rib eye you
know don't don't go get the nicer
because you're just not get it you're
not going to fully appreciate it all
right you're right you're right i'll
give it a try no you don't have to
change what you're doing this is just me
projecting my opinions on the way you
want to eat your food don't listen to me
this is just how i react
anyway um
uh i did it raw i would just bite a cow
if i could um
but they didn't think
the minbo they would bite me back
and they will again according to him um
um but then okay so he also realizes in
his home there's this uh crawl space he
finds this burner phone uh it's got
layla's number on it layla calls him
mark he's like who the hell is mark mark
starts talking to him in the mirror then
he starts getting stalked by the ghostly
khan shoe it freaks them out harrow
drags him down to the museum lectures
him about emmett's power how if only
amit if only emmett were around we could
have stopped hitler we could have
stopped whole pot we could stop their
armenian genocide what was amit doing
honestly yeah why where where was emmett
where was emmett then um and uh he tries
to actually judge mark but the scales
never balance which was super
interesting uh and then later that night
the demonic jackal chases mark through
the museum into the bathroom where
steven listens to his alter ego mark in
the mirrors i love the the
cinematography of the mirrors the
different reflections that were either
appearing in the mirrors or suddenly
reflections disappearing for the mirrors
things that were happening in real life
but not in the mirror of reflection just
a lot of great direction there and then
uh stephen surrenders to the warrior of
moon knight who beats that jackal so
savagely that a bunch of white people
and stand-up comedians are going to
demand oscar give up his oscar
i had to work it in
i had to work oh my god that jackal
shouldn't have said that [ __ ] eric you
shouldn't have said it
she kept it out of his mouth anyway
the question we're going to talk about
here how exactly arthur harrow's powers
work
uh the powers of ammit does this mean
that emmett can see into the future for
all of us and has powers over our
destiny or is
this whole judgment of people's souls is
it all [ __ ] at the end of the day
how much of what we've seen
can you gaze into the kitchen it's the
future
[Laughter]
those crocodiles are just blinking and
doing the raven i was like oh my god
we need raven on this show seriously
right now
raven just grabs our wrist that sucks
our life
i'm sorry you can't be here to see the
world we create
oh my god one of the best ways you can
support us here at new rockstars is by
grabbing some merch over at
newrockstarsmerch.com they have the
brand new moon knight latest obsession
shirt tomb of the moon god it's a cool
shirt design and when you buy it you're
going to get the chance to pay for a
shout out that will run during the
upcoming inside marvel episodes now we
don't have those shout outs yet because
um you know you haven't bought the
shirts yet you haven't done it yet but
once you do it next week you're gonna
see all kinds of crazy [ __ ] that being
right here
mt and i are gonna shout out a couple of
them respond to you answer your
questions shut down your theories
you will get mt's judgment yeah right
now but
pure bald nation judgment right here
just bring in your questions on the
latest obsession shirt immediately yeah
we'll have a tattoo on our arms of just
two different empty heads back yeah
that's the first tattoo i'll get it's
gonna be just me
judging others and the last tattoo it's
the only thing
anyway head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com check out that latest
obsession shirt and all the other great
moon night items like this this hoodies
bro looking good mt what's our first
question coming out of this episode of
moon night eric it's it's the main
question here i feel how the hell the
powers of arthur harrow and ahmet even
work yeah really the most curious part
of this premiere was the whole judgment
of emmett ritual that uh arthur herrera
places on his cult followers um he
balances the cane on their palms and
that came by the way is topped with the
back-to-back crocodile heads crocodiles
being the head of amit the egyptian
mythological demon beast who devours the
souls who are judged by anubis to be
unworthy amit has the head of a
crocodile the front body of a lion
the front body of a lion and the
hindquarters of a hippo
thick
too thick
day
you hate to see amit come but you love
to watch it
is this disrespectful i think it might
be disrespectful i don't know this is an
ancient pagan religion is anyone really
i don't know
this is a compliment if anything i would
never smack a god if they appeared in
front
and you know what no one worships emmett
they fear emmett
is like the beast it's not like one of
the gods in the indiana anyway um but
the kang uh the kang we're getting the
king
not yet but uh we're getting it
the cane swings back and forth like a
pendulum between the judge person and
harrow i just love the blocking of all
this by the way i love it with just like
little simple things can just be like
maneuvered that way and it just feels so
like ancient and
like you can imagine all these people
being like yes do a chanting um but um
while this while the cane swings the arm
tattoo activates the tattoo shows the
double crochets holding scales in their
mouths now mt i found this really
interesting because in egyptian
mythology it is not emmett who does the
judging it's anubis anubis holds the
scales weighing your heart against the
weight of a feather and if the if your
heart weighs more than the feather then
you go and damn it you know and until
yeah but the fact that amit now holds
the scales in her mouth reflects how the
eyes in the eyes of harrow and his
followers amit deserves to be the sole
judge and jury and executioner take
anubis out of the process uh because
this way you don't have to wait for the
symbol to commit their sins you can kind
of like in minority reports stop the
criminals in their tracks before they
get to harm in others before that old
lady gets to
plow in her buick through the playground
now uh
the tattoo seesaws until it bounces out
and turns green for a worthy soul or it
tips to one side and turns red for uh
our dear old
unworthy grandmother
sucked out and when stephen got a
glimpse of her yeah she looked like a
lifeless gray corpse kind of like
someone halfway through a sip from the
wrong holy grail like she chose poorly
uh or will choose poorly now um we
actually see a harrow's tattoo moving
both in the alps and in the london
museum so it's not just like in the
possible dream reality it's in what is
presented as objective reality safe to
assume that harrow's powers are real at
least as real as anything from steven's
perspective at the moment which is
something we should absolutely question
as we move ahead um we'll get to that
question but the episode also opens from
the objective point of view showing
arthur putting the broken glass into
sandals broken glass that he walks
around upon for every step which i just
think was this episode's way of proving
to us that harrow is the real deal he's
not just a showman right like he's not a
snake oil uh mysterio type uh a
trickster he has some kind of real power
yeah cause like he's not bleeding at all
like not at all he's not now it could
just be the guy's got thick
thick thick skin feet
calluses just all foot cases
he's got what peter jackson had the
hobbit actors wearing
foot foot shoes
oh yeah like that like captain america
one like chris evans has to run around
with those little fake shoes
he's got a hold of some of those and
then uh but it's only for us to make it
to the record i don't think so i think
the idea is that this guy's got some
real powers to him um
now one thing i want to point out empty
is that this is one of many recent
examples of mcu characters running afoul
of some cosmic legal system that they
previously didn't know existed remember
loki and silvi were similarly prosecuted
for future violations of destinies that
they didn't know was scripted out for
them by the tba and he remains aka kang
doctor strange is getting dragged before
some mysterious judicial body akin to
marvel's illuminati characters and what
if were judged by the watcher for the
mistakes that they made or in some cases
given second chances lighter sentences
cersei and the other eternals are facing
the judgment of eresham the judge based
on some other cryptic divine code i just
think there's a reason so many of the
mcu titles are pointed in this godly
legal direction they're obviously linked
at least thematically and perhaps
there's some kind of cosmic accords
scripted by some panel of vips that
we'll learn about a lot more soon
specifically i think there could be a
link between emmett and king uh pharaoh
ramatuch aka kang which i plan to
explore more in an upcoming video but
for ammit to arrive at a final judgment
for anyone means that emmett is in
agreement with he who remains in loki
that people's future decisions are
pre-scripted out for them and that
nothing we do can change that destiny
however emmett was unable to judge
stephen grant which is probably because
he has multiple identities inside of his
subconscious and each of those
identities might have different
destinies
that could make steven's very existence
in violation of
uh of a code prescribed by emmett and he
who remains and that stephen could exist
as a kind of multiversal dare i say
nexus being in this reality one who fits
in better with a multiverse of
possibilities
but really the question i have empty is
this the case because mark steven have
dissociative identity disorder or is
this because konchu is possessing them
is the show
saying that these two are the same thing
would that uh uncertain judgment happen
for anyone who had d.i.d hmm i think
that you know when you know we when we
see harrow and mark having this cover i
just said steve having their
conversation in the museum he says that
um steve has chaos inside of him and
like i made a video about this in the
past but i really do feel like chaos
magic chaos energy is a factor in this
show it's gonna be a huge factor
um moving forward and i think that
because of this chaos magic um in this
chaos energy it's able to flip mark's
brain into having two separate
identities so like because like you said
um he has these two identities the the
tattoo is like i can't really make a
judgment on these two people i'm only
one tattoo you're gonna have to make
another tattoo for two people maybe i
don't know um but yeah i was very
confused so yeah i feel like this it's
more than just a a your normal d.i.d
type of situation i think this is like a
a cosmic
sort of like influenced d.i.d type of
situation um that could be um happening
here but what do you think yeah i don't
want to speak out of turn and describing
the the symptoms and the nature of
dissociative identity disorder which is
a real
disorder they used to be called uh split
personalities or multiple personalities
disorder the technical term now is
dissociative identity disorder because
it's not like your brain is split or
broken necessarily it's just that you
disassociate in and out of different uh
identities and different forms that
exist in your subconscious
and that each of them have specific
characteristics specific ways of talking
they've done a lot of research in the
show apparently to uh to talk to mental
health experts and how this actually
works and you can tell oscar isaac has
really done the homework
but the thing is i think the show
definitely needs to answer that question
because i think the answer needs to be
that kanchu has uh has cursed mark in a
specific way that is unique and that we
aren't uh making a sweeping statement
about everyone suffering from
dissociative identity disorder i think
arthur hara was so surprised to see the
scales not reach a conclusion that that
must mean that mark is a unique case
that uh conscious possession of mark is
is what caused his uh condition but we
we don't really know if he had this
before or not we'll talk about that a
bit later um but i i think the the
conclusion that we should draw here for
now at least is that uh ahmet has real
power uh yes this is an example of
another god that exists in the mcu uh in
the same way that um
you know the thor movies established
that the norse gods are actually real
gods that exist in the cosmos that the
legends that we heard throughout mankind
and in human history were based on real
people the eternals made the same kind
of thesis statement right that uh
characters like icarus and athena you
know are all based on real people that
existed are real beings that existed so
i think the idea is that
in the mcu we're going to learn that
every being of mythology had some kind
of root and some super heroic figure
from history or someone with real power
um
and uh i like the idea that we're going
to meet all the gods at some point i
mean
i don't think they'll ever cross that
road and say that jesus christ
is the god that's based on some
superheroes you don't think we're gonna
see jesus in thor four you don't think
that's gonna happen jesus versus gore i
mean
i
maybe maybe they'll link something like
uh uh
adam warlock as like a christ figure
right like that he's very much
jesus is actually out of morocco and
then everyone will get pissed off people
will lose their minds new
oh yeah i think the closest they'll get
to be honest is mephisto like i think
the the christian devil will realize is
actually based on stories about this
godly demon figure mepisto um but yeah i
think the idea is that like emmett's
powers are real
insofar as anything we are seeing is
real
again i think all of what we're seeing
in either the realities that that
stephen
mark are bouncing in and out of i
i don't know if we could trust any of it
yet in the same way that like they
describe this as fight club which is
like famously a story that you know
the reality presented to you is actually
through an unreliable narrator right so
um
yeah i think we need to be definitely on
uh on the lookout here for some red
flags where things that are presented to
us is just normal baseline reality might
and like you know like something really
fishy happened at the end of the first
episode where like um art when when
steve he wanted to call him mark he's
not mark he's steve when steve gets off
the bus he sees era a harrow on the bus
like well as the bus drives away so like
is harrow even real like is that just in
his mind like what the heck was that
about like why didn't the arrow kill
that that's weird and like uh we don't
really know how steven got on that bus
because he wakes up already on the bus
was he stalking hero was harrow stalking
him were they in the same because it
looked like um um a connecting bus with
like different parts too right did haro
not see did hero not know that mark was
or stephen was on the bus until stephen
got off to look at him
like i think it was presented to us in
that moment as like
steven's kind of losing his mind that
things that were part of his dream are
actually part of his world and that
harrow is as much of a specter as uh
mark spector or as much as
uh
as kanchu is uh oh yeah
he's just lurking about by like a creep
in this episode oh my god so tall
so creepy right i love the design of
khan shoot like yes another thing that
they just pulled directly from the pages
of the comics but just looks so good i
never
thought that i would be as creeped out
by kanchu in real life but like it just
makes sense he's just a really creepy
looking dude and like it's just bones
the movement
the movement the way he like lurches
forward those long steps get the [ __ ]
out of here steve
the weird
the weird wisps of uh things are just
floating behind you like his hair he's
got this weird cobwebby hair that just
pokes out like the little details that
bring conch to life incredible
incredible well there's a lot more to
talk about from moon night but first we
want to thank some people who helped us
make this episode thanks to our friends
geology for sponsoring this episode moon
knight has had it bad between insomnia
and late night fights there's no sleep
get this man's eye cream and skin care
routine he's not alone 50 of the guys
suffer from under eye issues like the
dark under eye circles puffiness tired
eyes fine lines wrinkles this is where
geology comes in skincare shouldn't feel
like a gamble all geology's products are
made with scientifically proven
ingredients trusted by dermatologists
and cosmetic chemists start with a
complete trial set a 30-day supply of
face wash vital morning face cream
repairing night cream and nourishing eye
cream includes two bottles of face wash
one for the sink and one for the shower
or to take with you to the gym the part
we like about geology is they do the
hard work of finding the right products
for you and just have you get to use
them their mantra is make handsome a
habit which is way better than saying
make tired eyes a habit make a handsome
habit so head on over to geology.com and
take their free skincare quiz to save up
to 50 off your first 30 days trial or
just click the link in the description
that's g e o l o g i e dot com or click
the link below to save 50 off on your 30
day trial and speaking of sleep you
might lose some shut eye due to the
crime fighting but you don't want to
miss out on rest because of a bad
mattress that's why we love our helix
mattresses so much
feeling sleep has a quiz that matches
your body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you they have soft medium and firm
mattresses mattress is great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot even a helix
plus mattress for plus size sleepers the
healing plus mattress is the best i
sleep on that every night is the best
yeah mt loves his i got a helix mattress
i love mine it feels like mtni are
sleeping on the same mattress connected
through some kind of cosmic rift and
we're all just drifting off this slum
when we sleep we can connect our dreams
together via the helix wi-fi it's the
best we do so you know when i have my
event horizon
horror dreams i drag mt into hell with
me yeah we both have barbed wire wrapped
around our faces
that's literally the recurring dream
i've had for the past few days it's
awful really oh my
uh-huh
yup
but mt when we uh get the right kind of
sleep on a helix mattress those dreams
don't last very long and we wake up
feeling great so it's all worth it the
mattress shifts right to your door for
free no need to go to a mattress store
just go to helixsleep.com
inside marvel take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10 year warranty and you get to try it
out for 100 nights risk-free you'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you're going to love it helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helix sleep.com inside
marvel all right mt back to moon knight
what's our next question well eric did
kanchu cause mark's dissociative
identity disorder or did he have d.i.d
before meeting kanchu yeah so that's an
interesting question i think the show
really needs to answer in the comics it
really goes back and forth because
initially in the 80s moon knight was not
at all described as someone with
dissociative identity disorder or
schizophrenia or anything
people didn't even use the term
dissociative identity disorder back then
they called it like split personality
disorder or just like more offensive
things to describe people going through
issues um really moon knight was just uh
presented as a batman style vigilante
with lots of alter egos nothing more to
it but uh in later comics they started
to explore the mental health side of
this and then um and warren ellis is
running the comics in 2014 um
at first mark spector thinks he might
have did but it stated that that is not
the case konchu is just a real entity
living inside of mark's head and
outsiders see this and diagnose it as
did but all of mark's alter egos are
really defined as machinations of
khanshu and then in the 2016 run of the
comics it suggests that mark actually
had did or schizophrenia or something
when he was a kid and that all those
identities were also created by khan shu
who had who was around him when he was a
kid um but uh maybe konchu
was presented as being unstuck from time
and just a forever demon in mark's
destined timeline or maybe that that
could have been a false projected memory
by konshu and mark's adult presence um
when he thinks back on those memories he
thinks back on kanchu being there
alongside him we just don't really know
yeah
purposely have made it very like
ambiguous throughout time as to like
what's going on with mark just so like
whoever has the reins to who was writing
moonlight at the time can just write
whatever they want and just be as
creative with the character as they want
so right exactly um and in the comics
they always infuse mark's issues with
conscious possession so that the the two
are really both owned as both a
superpower and a curse just an
experience that mark is going through it
just remains to be seen if this series
is going to say mark spectre previously
had dissociative identity disorder
before ever meeting konchu and if so
what traumatic event in his younger days
might have caused that or if conscious
possessing him is what caused the d.i.d
and if so does that mean khanshu causes
every avatar he's possessed in the past
or in the future to also have d.i.d or
just mark is a different unique avatar
who reacts this way to khan should
possessing him and if so why that's the
case um i i really think at the end of
the day conscious possessing mark could
certainly be traumatic enough to result
in d.i.d in mark and we don't really
know why trauma causes certain people to
react by having this issue of
dissociative identity disorder but i
think we need to know if mark was unique
in that side effect uh and and what
particularly about mark's past causes
that um or if this is just something
that conscious does to everyone what do
you think empty are they gonna stay
uh nebulous about this or are they gonna
try to answer some of those questions i
think people might have some negative
reactions here i think that you know
if they do address the the whole issue
or the how you know the the origins of
um steve's d.i.d
i think that they'll have to be very
very obviously very tactful and like
approach it very like smartly um but i
i you know i think that they they might
have to honestly during this series
because like they are tackling such a
huge topic and like this is the first
hero
um
the first like major hero i guess that
has really a mental illness i mean we do
have wand division and like wanda
struggling with the depression and all
that but like this is like a you know
d.i.d like this is the first type of
hero that we're getting um
like this so like i just feel like at
some point during this season we're
gonna get a brain scan type of moment
where like he's gonna be in a hospital
and be like all right this is what's
going on like this is where his d.i.d or
like or or he's always had the idea or
like this is where it's coming from or
or something but yeah i think that we'll
get some type of answer there um
yeah i think um it's it's tough it's
definitely a hard question to answer
because you don't want you know dummies
watching the show thinking that oh
someone who has d.i.d between this and
that james mcavoy movie split that means
you could be a super one of your
identities could be a superhero so hey
wake up in there is there a superhero
height in there you should surrender
control to them because i want to hang
out with them instead of with you like
you don't want that to be the case you
want like this to educate people about
dissociative identity disorder
but i think they just need to make it
clear that mark's superhero nature comes
from konshu um this associative identity
disorder is a psychological side effect
from that um but it's not like
you having d.i.d is a kind of superhero
thing it just makes it harder to also be
a superhero then because when you're in
these situations it you don't know who's
at the wheel in that moment and you it's
you gotta have that person
make the decision to surrender control
to one of the other identities so that
that identity can be the superhero this
isn't meant to be like a fun wish
fulfillment thing this is like
uh a curse story and how the challenges
of having to walk every day with that
curse
um
so as as unfun as watching someone be a
superhero can be because i got to tell
you it's it's pretty fun to watch
the [ __ ] out of a jackal in a bathroom
yeah moonlight's a pretty fun superhero
to watch gotta say yeah but not one i
would want to be at the end of the day
oh yeah no no definitely not um for sure
i mean hulk seems a bit more fun uh or
like you know could be tony stark just
fly around in a cool iron suit yeah i
wouldn't want to be either i don't want
to be moon knight or vision those are
the two i would not want to be um in the
fc which is mainly vision mostly but not
vision vision just dies
i mean that's something that i hope we
explore more in the mcu with the how how
being a superhero is a witch fulfillment
it kind of sucks
yeah like it's hard to be a superhero
you wouldn't want that life yeah um so i
love those kind of stories in the mcu
and i hope that they actually get into
that in miss marvel the show they're
coming up because like it's she's we
have this girl that's glorified
superheroes but like it's not all great
and like it's actually quite shitty as
we see it from the audience perspectives
perspective from like events like civil
war it's not fun all the time
so yeah i do like that and it's and
hopefully a theme i think definitely
will be uh pursued and explored in thor
love and thunder like that's going to be
a huge choice for jane foster so when
he's going through cancer right she
could power up with mjolnir to become
lady thor but in the jason erin comics
that resets her chemo every time she
does that so she's back to square one
and she's like well i can escape and be
a superhero or i can actually deal with
my problems right now
fascinating debate to have with oneself
that i hope this movie leans into like i
love how like the marvel studios is like
showing us like different heroes like
that like heroes with cancer here's a
did heroes with uh deaf heroes like we
need more variety like that and so i
hope the mcu moves forward um telling
more stories like that yeah and blind
heroes as well now with daredevil
absolutely
fascinating story right um
anyway uh let's talk about this golden
scarab
what do you think is the this is clearly
the macguffin of the story right now
this is our ark of the covenant uh what
is the significance do you think of this
scarab um well i i
kevin feige texted me earlier and he
told me that um
there's something about the cave of
wonders and a diamond in the rough um
something something about that something
about aladdin i think aladdin's gonna
come just kidding now um that's all i
could think of when i saw the scare of
like this is aladdin this is true
just kidding
[Laughter]
uh but no i think that this scarab is
gonna be like the huge uh obvious like
like you said the huge mcguffin of the
series and it might just be
um what you know arthur needs to fulfill
his huge mission then like obviously
they wanted enough to to kill um to kill
moon knight and so i think that this is
just gonna be um some type of artifact
that
might help him get somewhere or like
might have like might be a key of some
sort like it might open up and like
actually be like a maybe it's a locket
who knows um but like it's it's
definitely helping him reach amit it's
just to some capacity i don't know what
do you think yeah i think and i'm only
basing this on trailer footage where you
see a shot of uh arthur harrow in the
desert with the
scarab hovering over his hand oh that's
right i'm pointing yeah you know so i i
kind of feel like it's got to be a
compass leading to somewhere some
ancient tomb some ruins that arthur
herrera wants to get to maybe the golden
age i mean knowing that he wants to he
mentioned wanting to unleash her or
bring back emmett to resurrect her like
oh brave of you for subjecting yourself
to emmett's judgment before emmett comes
back before he is here so like i think
they want to bring back or resurrect
emmett or unleash the beast in the world
going to try to find where amit is
trapped and then on uncork that i i
guess to use the lost terp sort of like
a dweller of darkness style it's like
find out just
everyone's trying to unleash these
beasts why not just keep the beast in
the cave seriously they were finding the
cases all those for millennials we're
trying to create train these beasts let
them just sleep the night
and view it as their little home
exactly jesus christ they like their
crate uh anyway
um all right final question empty and
this is really the biggest question i
think we're gonna have in this series
how much of what we are seeing is real
how much is this all a dream is this all
a fantasy a delusion inside someone's
head
i think that
for the most part
i think what we're seeing is real i
think like like during that elevator
sequence when like that woman turned
into conscious that wasn't real but like
you know like it seems that he's
legit because like at the end of this
episode we see the jackal attack him but
like the jackal is actually interacting
with the environment and like hitting
things around and like it seems that
things actually happen there i don't
think that mark is like imagining that
jack i think that jackal is actually
there so like i think it's a mix of
mostly reality magic reality but like
some kind of like all right i'm kind of
seeing things but what do you think see
i don't know i have to re-watch it and i
will for the breakdown but like the it
doesn't look like the jackal is really
interacting like i don't know if we see
obviously it's a cgi jackal anyway but
like i think they shoot it in a specific
way where mark pulls down the the
shelves in front of it and it jumps over
it it definitely climbs on stuff true
but i don't know i don't know if it's
actually ripping stuff down and the
camera cuts away from the bathroom and
then we cut back in and see all the the
sink smash but like mark himself could
have smashed those
yo like that bathroom was messed up oh
what is mark going to say after that
what is steve gonna say
who knows um to me you mentioned the
elevator sequence that's what i'm hung
up on the this elevator is going up and
down the building in chaotic waste he
was hitting ground floor and then it
goes down to the third opens up no one
summoned it down to the second uh
conscious at the end of the hallway if
konchu is supposed to be like a stand-in
for that old woman she was at the other
end of that hallway who summoned this
elevator for it to stop on the second
floor and it goes back up to the fifth
floor no one if it was a down oriented
elevator you know if you get on an
elevator that is headed down even if you
press the button for the fifth floor
it's gonna go down to the ground floor
first before it goes back
up now yeah maybe there's just faulty
wiring in this elevator sure
but like it was working otherwise to get
to where it needed to go there's just
all kinds of like
faulty logic i also think like
when when mark was flipping through the
pages researching the any ad the way
that any ad was listed and the people
listed as being among the iniad is not
correct and if mark is supposed to be an
expert in egyptian mythology like maybe
there are other interpretations of the
egyptian mythology and i'm not as well
versed on it but it seems like even the
textbook that mark or that stephen had
used to say this is who and who isn't
supposed to be listed on the any ad like
even that seemed to be wrong seemed to
be like faulty it's like someone who um
has that kind of like
uh who are these people who like
who think that they're experts based off
of reading like a wikipedia article on
something or watching one youtube video
on it and so they'll go to their trivia
night with their friends be like
actually i do know on this but they have
that false sense of expertise uh and
realistically they don't have any
degrees or any actual expertise in this
stuff but like in their own mind's eye
they view themselves as these experts on
these things just because they've done a
little bit of homework on it uh is that
who we're seeing now with with stephen
grant is he actually
a true nerd a true expert i mean look at
this the show is forcing us to like ask
a question of what makes someone's
expertise true and it's someone a real
nerd it's like asking us to question who
the gatekeepers are and who keeps the
gatekeepers empty
no but no like this is this all is like
really interesting because like it makes
me think like what if
humanity because of like whoever's in
charge of the a need or any ad i don't
know how to say it um how do you say it
i need an idiot anyhow and yeah yeah so
like what if whoever's in charge of the
idiad is feeding people like you're
right here's the true any iniad after
like um i don't know some some fallout
happened between the gods and like two
gods got kicked out and so like everyone
except for mark who has consciou in his
head believes that there are seven so
like i'm wondering something happened
wow there's like some kind of mass gas
lighting it's either sprite going in
there like changing like a ministry of
truthing everything so that everything
prints out in a different way or it's
like runes of cough calling all of
society exactly so that we all forget
who really is on the any ad wow
you just blew my mind right now that
would be wild i
what i love about the show is it's
presenting to us like an uncertainty of
time and an uncertainty of reality like
mark has no idea how much time has pas i
keep saying mark but stephen has no idea
how much time has passed over the
weekend man you know someone's going to
turn that into a meme of like sir it's
sunday oh no
no
no
it was on my calendar
but like yeah i think uh like the fact
that mark or steven never really knows
what day of the week it is we don't know
how much time has passed but we also
don't know what
reality what the basic tenets of reality
are right now whether our fish has a
thin that works or not like this show
has us questioning all that stuff so
that we're kind of trapped in this
unreliable narrator headspace like we're
watching fight club or like we're
watching memento or like we're watching
joker we can't really trust basic things
not just stuff that's presented to be
fictitious or meant to be fantastical
like seeing conscious standing on the
side of the street even basic stuff like
what you read on the page of a book can
we really trust that right now and it's
such a delightful place of uncertainty
to be in as we plunge into the series
i hope i hope everyone can appreciate
those little subtleties i love a good
mystery question everything in this show
um because i i think this is the kind of
show that's going to turn everything on
its head episode after episode and we'll
leave it there for this episode of
inside marvel the breakdown is coming
out later today it's exciting don't
forget of course to check out all the
great merch options at
newarkstoresmerch.com
uh that limited edition um latest
obsession moon night shirt really the
best way to support this channel and
then write in your shout out so we'll uh
we'll react we want to read them we want
to read them so bad we want to know
follow me at eavos follow mt
mastertainment uh subscribe to inside
marvel wherever you get your podcast
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching late again let us get us
late latest skaters latest gators
goodbye mum
goodbye
you